President Biden hosted South Korea's
president last night at the White House
State Dinner President Biden said the
visit has brought the U.S and South
Korea closer together as allies earlier
the two leaders announced a new
agreement that would deter North Korean
aggression Nancy Cortez is at the White
House Nancy good morning
Nate good morning to you the president
hosted his South Korean counterpart at
what was only the second official state
dinner of the pride in presidency here
at the White House a rare honor meant to
send a message to North Korea and to
China about the strength of this
Alliance
film star Angelina Jolie Utah senator
Mitt Romney and Home Design gurus chip
and Joanna Gaines were among those
invited to the White House State dinner
[Music]
where even the guest of honor got in on
some of the night's performances the
president and first lady hosted South
Korean president Yun sukul and his wife
after a busy day of meetings where the
two leaders announced new military
agreements aimed at deterring North
Korea from launching more nuclear
missile tests the U.S will dock a
nuclear ballistic submarine in South
Korea temporarily something that hasn't
happened since the early 80s we also see
it in the way we're doubling down on our
cooperation as allies even as the dprk
ramps up its challenges as Mr Biden
focused on foreign policy his new
campaign was launching its first
re-election ad arguing that American
freedoms are at stake they're under
attack by an extreme movement that seeks
to overturn elections ban books and
eliminate a woman's right to choose in
Arkansas former Governor ASA Hutchinson
became the newest Republican candidate
hoping to take on President Biden every
hard-working American family gets a
double hit from the Biden economy
Hutchinson is 72 and Mr Biden who is 80
addressed concerns about his age on
Wednesday I took a hard look at it
before I decided to run and I feel good
President Biden said he understands why
people have questions about his age he
said he would have those questions too
but he argued he doesn't feel like he's
80. the South Korean president remains
here in Washington today he's going to
address a joint session of Congress the
first South Korean president to do so in
a decade Gail
and we see he likes to sing too Nancy
thank you very much